[Music]
so what you see here is the
high resolution ccd solar spectrum so
that's
basically the rainbow of the sun in its
full detail
and this was obtained kind of
professionally not by me um by the
current steam at harvard
and i think about this image all the
time i have this framed in my house you
know there's just a complexity to all
these lines and each line
corresponds to an atom or a molecule at
the edge of the sun
and
as a spectroscopist in space we're just
always counting photons and so i thought
okay
for my new scale i'm going to look at
something that has an abundance of
photons so i was just trying to look at
the sun too but with my own handheld
spectrometer that i keep in my purse
just in case a
interesting light source comes my way
and i felt similarly to jess that there
was an elusiveness to these images i was
trying to capture both the sky and the
spectrum of light from the sun and you
can see that all of those
millions actually billions of absorption
lines from the previous picture
completely disappear and it just looks
like a continuous
rainbow and i can imagine for the first
people who saw the the lines in the
spectrum of the sun
apparently so the story goes they
thought it was dead they thought it was
a problem with their prism
and i can totally imagine that because
from this perspective the sun just seems
like a continuous source of light no
interruptions
and and then what i found was it was
almost impossible to get the spectrum
and the sky in focus which of course
makes sense to anyone here does
photography but that hadn't even crossed
my mind in my mind this photograph would
have been kind of a beautiful just
add just a position and instead i could
only focus on the spectrum
so then i tried something close to home
um
and i
saw that the light in my hallway was old
and old lights tend to not be you know
led continued spectrum and i was not
disappointed so it's just a beautiful
emission spectrum
and
this was such a pleasure to actually try
and capture but the elusiveness was so
so true at this point i was trying to
get the camera aligned with the
spectroscope and the light hitting just
right and i was trying to get the echo
of the spectra the edges spectrometer
and
even though i had an abundance of
photons i didn't have any stability and
so
um
i
i really struggled with this and i have
a whole new appreciation for the
instruments i use and the architecture
and engineering that goes into them
because spectra is hard at every scale
it seems
[Music]
[Music]
you